il ya aussi d'autres personnes qui ont
été contaminées par l'aco vide alors
qu'elles étaient vaccinés au niveau
notamment en israël où on a une centaine
de cas donc monsieur dr délépine qu'est
ce qu'on dit à sao et qu'est ce qu'on
dit et les semaines et mois j'ai coûte
ce que dit olivier ferrand olivier
veyrat santé a répondu au conseil d'état
lorsqu'un malade
enfin pas un malade un cobaye les
vaccins s'étaient fait vacciner avec ses
deux vaccins dit je veux sortir de mon
époque puisque je suis vacciné et il lui
est interdit en lisant le vaccin ne
protège pas contre la maladie
il a dit oui on poussait pas parce que
vous êtes vacciné qu'ils ne risquaient
pas battre je vais demander à gadji mis
au fait vacciner donc dû me pour pas
voir deux formes graves de kobe tu sais
quoi en fait le truc alors je pense
qu'il faut mettre vos connaissances à
jour et finalement malheureusement ça
évolue jour après jour et c'est vrai que
le discours peut évoluer ce concert il
faut rassurer les gens car cyril vous
avez raison lorsqu'on lit le titre
s'inquiétant bah oui c'est vaccinant
attrape le comité puis quand on lit dans
les lignes et qu'on se dit finalement ce
dont on s'aperçoit c'est que les
personnes qui sont malheureusement
décédés ce absolument horrible et bien
était immunodéprimée ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'elle avait un système
immunitaire qui est moins performant
oui donc on sait que la vaccination sera
peut-être un peu moins efficace raison
pour laquelle on propose aux personnes
qui vont avoir une transplantation
d'organes les patients qui sont dialysés
on leur propose une troisième injection
justement pour booster leur système
immunitaire car on sait qu'on n'est pas
tous égaux face à la vaccination
maintenant on sait qu'en situation
d'études est en situation réelle ça
marche deux raisons la première une
énorme études en angleterre 23000
soignants qui ont été vaccinés
correctement avec deux doses vaccin avec
arn
on a pris deux groupes un groupe
d'actionnaires ou vacciner est bien dans
le groupe vacciné on a 70 cas dans le
groupe non vaccinés en a 1000
donc on a une preuve quand même de
l'efficacité et puis regardez ce qui se
passe en angleterre en israël en
angleterre on a réussi à vaincre
l'épidémie avec n'ont fait il ya eu deux
fois plus de morts depuis l'invalidation
en angleterre il ya en a un goy terre
avant la vaccination y avait soixante
deux mille morts actuellement il y en a
cent vingt-sept mille donc la halle avec
ce réseau les deux mois qui ont suivi la
vaccination ont été les deux mois les
plus mortelles du conan
la même chose lui franchement non mais
franchement si c'est si vous ne pouvez
pas dire ça a marché alors on a doublé
le nombre de morts en deux mois alors
qu'ils en avaient pouvez pas dire aux
gens et vous allez réalité regarder l'om
et c'est là vers le relise et les
chiffres de l'om est désolé c'est
l'arrêt regarder les chiffres
je laisse justement vont devenir et je
pense que vous avez une lourde
responsabilité dans la désinformation
que rien du tout mais si l'on fait de
donner les chiffres de l'om est une des
informations d'ici c'est nouveau il
attend des libyens les morts entre le
1er février 2020 20 février février 2020
et le 21 le 7 décembre début de la
vaccination combien de morts la combine
de l'ordination a commencé le 2 décembre
en angleterre d'accord pour driver et le
30 décembre à la faveur mais cas où il a
les qualités et le 25 février de 380 3
morts par semaine en angleterre
ouais ça marche de 140 semaine et le 10
avril
36 ah oui j'avais besoin et où les gens
à risque
effectivement il ya eu d'abord le
problème c'est que vous avez nettoyer en
deux mois tout ce qui est l'équivalent
de tous qui a eu lieu en dix mois
alors effectivement après vous enlevez
moi parce que ne meurt pas tout le monde
ne meure les gens à risque est très
vieux à commodité la question il ya un
an mais si on est sûr qu'elle allait
poursuivre tout ça ça saoule et acima
juste les chéris zidor la question qu'on
se pose tous c'est comment on peut être
vaccinés et avoir la coved c'est tout
con israël on l'a vu il ya une centaine
de cas jimmy comme on explique ck mais
attendait déjà en france dans un premier
temps on a l'équivalent on vous le dit
tous les jours d'un airbus a380 qui se
crashe et qui meurt en israël ils ont eu
hier l'équivalent d'une twingo qui se
crashe quatre morts au bout d'un moment
on peut aussi se poser des questions de
se dire là finalement ça marche en
revanche il faut bien comprendre que
lorsqu'on est vacciné il ya une double
stratégie la première puce en israël a
pour pour tout est ouvert donc
exactement est en effet un excellent
texas au texas tout est ouvert il ya pas
non plus dans merde alors faut arrêter
de séméac et en inde ont été ouverts
c'est la cata ce nous alors l'air malin
c'est ma vraie lame fait beaucoup mieux
que nous il ya dix fois moins de morts
en inde qu'en france on millions
d'habitants voire millions parmi eux le
temps mais bien entendu je parle
toujours d'un million d'habitants alors
qu'on ne dise pas que l'un d'eux c'est
l'horreur actuellement les deux pouces
et qu'ils ont vacciné
des gens meurent sur les trottoirs en
inde parce qu'il manque d'oxygène donc
dire que ça se passe bien distincts
jeudi que peu de dire que la france est
très bien alors qu'on est dix fois plus
de morts par million d'habitants
jeudi que la vaccination pour venir la
vaccin est un peu plus discret
vaccination vous protège doublement à
titre personnel lorsque je vaccine je
vous protège ça vous évite un d'avoir la
maladie on sait vous êtes moins
transmise à l'est - transmettre le virus
et donc finalement moins le propager et
3 ça va éviter les formes graves mais
parce qu'on n'a jamais démontré que le
vaccin était capable d'empêcher les
transmissions et s'essaye ça que je vous
écris pas vous faire un jour sinon dix
ans d'études ne suis pas fait mention
fut ainsi très écouté le récit est quand
même monsieur qui en france il est même
il était je crois que c'est bon voilà le
sud et free ci a bien dit qu'on ne
pouvait pas se fier pour empêcher les
transmissions il a écrit dans le lancet
de cancer quand ça il ya des noirs
samediet de m'élancer payer deux
semaines nouveau métrage en
malheureusement au viala jeu avant de
venir j'ai regardé gel de bricy a agi
juste avant de venir je me suis dit
tiens
est ce que finalement on en train de se
tromper parce qu'on a le droit de se
remettre en question la suite de
nombreuses études sont en train de
montrer et de prouver notamment en
israël que la transmission du virus
chute avec la vaccination c'est à dire
qu'on va vaincre l'épidémie
grâce à la vaccination on se rend compte
en ce moment dans les hôpitaux on l'a on
l'a vu dans les airs dans les reportages
que l'âge est en train de baisser on a
des patients de plus en plus jeunes
pourquoi c'est parce qu on a vacciné les
fragiles les plus de 75 ans quand on le
regarde
ils sont à trois quarts vacciner donc à
trois quarts protéger ça veut dire que
la vaccination c'est une chance
et lorsque nous allons accélérer on a
une perspective de sortie donc il faut
c'est fou c'est à leur donner un rôle à
delfraissy elle est clairement écrit et
ça vous pouvez le lire et les dinky à
une évasion des militaires on compte
plusieurs articles plusieurs articles
sérieux internationaux montrent qu'une
évasion et me dire qui se produit soit
parce que les gens ont déjà été atteints
soit parce qu'ils ont été vaccinées
s'est mis en tout la fumée et qu'on ne
peut plus attendre des vaccins à la fin
de cette chose en fait qu'est-ce qu'on
fait alors eh ben on fait on doit la
chine n'ont jamais keane ont fait non
j'ai pas du sein je suis pas un vendeur
de vaccins de médicaments
je dis qu'on fait comme la suède la
suède a encore moins de morts que nous
et vous comme les pays bas ont fait quoi
ils ont ils fait ouais mais ils ont fait
une unité reconnaissent que vous ne
connaissez pas vous et collectif a pas
tellement non non j'ai pas parlé
d'ailleurs alors je sais pas non déçu
donne
jamie par b du mini c'est non non non
les choses est stratège et vous tenez
est ce que vous êtes ville lui on est
d'accord c'est le nom est ce que vous
avez lu ce qu'a dit le patron de
l'épidémiologie en scène il a jamais
parlé début des 8es collectif il faut
que moi les autres l'ont dit les autres
l'envié lui il ya quelques mois elle a
dit je pense qu'on a atteint la nuitée
collectif c'est ce qui anime et ce
n'était pas une stratégie il s'est
défendu de ça on l'accusé tête qu'on
fait maintenant alors si on est bien on
fait ce que je sais ce qu'on a fait lors
de la grippe asiatique vous souhaitez
beaucoup trop jeune j'avais 13 ans j'ai
vécu la veille pédiatrique en france je
vous rappelle de ses dribbles asiatique
a tué cent mille français
alors on a fait quoi eh ben on n'a rien
fait on les gens qui était malade il
rester chez eux
oui s'isolait ils n'allaient pas à
l'école si c'est à dire parce que la
grippe passe par les enfants et puis et
puis les gens ont vécu normalement
embrasé depuis la vérité définition ne
peut pas modéliser il faut frapper des
risées elle pas un modèle c'est une
expérience c'était de vous vous vivez et
sur les rêves de modèles de
mathématiques moi je regarde sur
l'expérience médical est pas son
expérience médicale on n'a jamais fait
ce qu'on nous a imposée qu'elle
confinement servant enfermés ensemble
les malades et les enfants au jimmy
jimmy comment se fait-il qu'ils aient
des cas de co vide quand on a été
vaccinée comment on peut l'attraper
alors ils sont très rares déjà dans un
premier temps c'est ce que vous le dire
mais qu'est ce que c'est que le vaccin
est chaud c'est une marche pas accès il
marche une fois sur deux on his que vous
voulez dans un instant le docteur des
lipides va vous raconter l'histoire des
notes du kentucky
j'ai pris ça depuis tout à l'heure et
demie je suis très heureux l'histoire
des nobles kentucky et vous allez voir
que c'est pas tout à fait ce qu'on croit
jimmy mobile
non mais donc là on se fait vacciner
quand on fait vacciner on se dit qu'on
se dit on a moins de chances d'attraper
la lacc au vide
trois choses 1 devait avoir la maladie
deux pas la transmettre et 3 pas de
faire de forme grave
mais ce qu'on a besoin c'est d'être tous
vaccinés pour diminuer la pression de
sélection du virus et d'éviter de
rencontrer le virus ça veut dire que
quand on a un vaccin efficace à 90%
si l'épidémie circule énormément et bien
vous allez tôt ou tard tombé sur le
virus
en revanche quand on aura vaincu
l'épidémie est bien 90 % d'efficacité
baisse est largement suffisant donc ce
vaccin feiler moderna alors un coup
c'était astrazeneca qu'elle est pas
maintenant ces files heures moderna je
pense qu'au bout d'un moment fort a été
donné de mauvaises nouvelles et
d'expliquer que grâce à la vaccination
va pas et au passé
vivre avec cette maladie bien parce
qu'on voit qu'à chaque fois il ya de
nombreux variant qui arrive c'est
compliqué on nous dit une fois que le
var c'est la marche lahoud fois c'est
compliqué marche pas sur toutes les
personnes apprécier les plus des mois de
démarches que sur les plus de 55 ans ou
les moins de 55 ans et les plus de 55
ans pour l'astra zenica est ce qu'à un
moment on va pas se dire de façon quoi
qu'il arrive il va falloir qu'on vive
avec la planète vivent avec avec cesser
cette maladie c'est possible qu'ils font
vivre différemment ça veut dire ne pas
retrouver exactement la vie d'avant mais
peut-être qu'en faisant attention ce
faisant tester avec des autotests avec
la vaccination en faisant pas n'importe
quoi bien peut-être qu'on va n'ont pas
retrouvé une vie je pense qu'on puisse
préserver une vie normale moi je jose 9
essais malheur car je pense que tout se
passait pour être pessimiste mais je
vous dis dans les prochaines années moi
je vois pas deux comme ça de gens qui
vont se prendre dans les bras qui se
connaissent pas je vois pas ça dans le
sang je vous rassure la jeunesse
européenne commence à le faire ouais
aller ya les fameux souhaite qu'ils sont
décriés par tous nos nos ayatollahs du
co lead et c'est très cruel que tout
s'est fait faire des soirées moss ou
pardon des soirées à des soirées vous je
suis un âge où je ne fais pas vraiment d
aussi battant des patients alors et donc
oui pour vous vous êtes pour les soirées
vous êtes pour je pense attention pop
j'ai pas dit qu'il fallait faire des
soirées de légende 85 ans d'accord ça me
paraît être un peu imprudent mais par
contre que les jeunes se rencontrent et
bien ça leur fera le plus grand bien il
se recentre ont pu par la fenêtre
2 ça va leur permettre de se contaminer
et c'est la grande chance si on veut se
débarrasser de la maladie effectivement
les enfants ne risquent rien de cette
maladie tout le monde est d'accord
personne vous n'allez pas de sortir une
étude qui n'existe pas les enfants ne
risquent rien de cette maladie là une
fois qu'on a attrapé la maladie on ne
leur fait pas sur les millions de car2go
vite déclaré al om s il ya eu trois
quarts je crois de gens qui auront qu'on
leur a chuté après un qu'ovide naturel
donc on a une immunité qui est certaine
adam ans avec un an de recul pour
l'instant puisque l'épidémie qui
n'existait pas avant
je vous disais un truc aussi misé ans on
s'était tous contaminés
ouais je dis ce serait vraiment un grand
bonheur parce que il y effectivement ils
feront le barrage à la maladie dans le
futur je vous dirai ce qu'il m'a dit un
truc intéressant
des épines pendant la pause ici il me
disait le hac au vide est le révélateur
de l'état de santé de certaines
personnes quand ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que l'on meurt du coc vite
quand on devait mourir la durée de vie
moyenne en france est de 84 ans la durée
moyenne de des morts de communes et 85
ans n'y a pas tant d'ennemis en fait
j'ai jamais dit cela est naturel en fait
non j'ai dit que c'est cette pandémie il
ya beaucoup de virus qui circule ni à
une vraie maladie
cette maladie tue les gens qui sont le
fragile les voyages naturel nettoyage
naturel pardonnez moi mais je referme et
absolument oui elle voudrait dire que
donc est des gens c'est naturel on s'en
fiche il en est destiné à leur
conscience que la balaye la ville se
termine par la mort quoi qu'on fasse des
foyers mais c'est la réalité entre vous
pouvez dire que c'est parce que ça la
réalité c'est vraiment dire ça mais
fixiez monsieur est ce qu'on doit mourir
asphyxié à 80 ans 85 ans à vous en train
de dire ça nettoyage mais vous êtes un
danger public non en plus ou pas une
chose que vous ne maîtrisez pas vous
êtes face à un médecin non mais
reprenons là et embellissent à ce que
les gens ils sont complètement perdus
moi je vais vous dire j'ai un cachet
mois de papa et j'en ai parlé me qui est
lié alizés je vais vous dire un truc
pour protéger mon père il faut que moi
elle me faire vacciner aussi parce que
mes poils frappé six nations mais je
suis désolé vous ne pourrez pas y ont
déjà réagi
beaucoup de gens qui rallie sur ce que
vous avez dit il va traîner les choses
n'ont jamais lu tree legends
c'est totalement différent alors comme
la grille est insupportable ce que vous
dites c'est à dire quasiment bravo le
virus il valait j'ai dit ça c'est ce
qu'on entend c'est comme une guerre et
va y avoir des sacrifiés dans génération
nos vieux nos personnes âgées peuvent
mourir mais c'est pas grave il serait
mort il savait si c'est ce que vous
dites monsieur non mais j'ai dit que je
la mets les outils de mourir mourir
despinoy je pense oui
les salaires moyens il ya plein de gens
qui ont des pneus médiums et grand-père
une 80 ans de 85 ans pour eux y voient
pas leur âge ils ont juste envie de
bruit et moment encore de bonheur avec
leurs grands pères ou leurs grandes fm
l'aco vide est passée par là et ça a
accéléré
mine de rien leur mort je suis désolé
c'est pas des gens qui devait mourir
voilà tout de suite et à accélérer
accélérer leur mort donc on voulait vous
avez un gardien de 85 ans que vous avez
un grand père que vous aimez une grand
mère que vous adorez chaque jour de
gagner ainsi été rassurés année là elle
a le lac au vide on va pas dire que 16
mine de rien ça ça accélère donc c'est
pas des gens qui devait mourir en rien
n'y fait des calculs très précis qui ont
été faits sur ce problème combien
d'années d'années perdues par le cos
vide et on se rend compte que le que le
coc vide à tuer ap fait perdre très peu
d'années de vie c'est faux non je suis
quand même parce que vous composez deux
choses l'espérance de vie à la naissance
ou à dire 85 ans et l'espérance de vie
une fois que vous avez atteint ses 85
ans c'est à dire qu'une fois que vous
êtes arrivé à 85 ans et dont les noms
étaient alignés zunien ont tenu compte
de sa fille ils ont dit at-elle âge on
attelle et iso perdu 10 ans d'espérance
de vie les jantes 68,094 ont perdu dix
ans d'espérance aussi une sélection
naturelle etc du nettoyage nantes
médecin c'est ça c'est ça vous avez
consacré votre vie à dire aux gens m'a
finalement si vous mourez sens et c'est
l'âge élections ces nettoyages attendait
parce que c'est pas digne du de la
fonction de docteur non non je suis
désolé
d'abord je n'ai pas dis ça je dis que
simplement
cette maladie touche les gens très âgés
à forte qu'au perdent nord-midi téoz et
fait un tour dans les services devrait
moins sûr
oui le ministre a dit attention les
jeunes sont touchés
qu'est ce qui s'est passé on est passé
de 67 ans à 63 ans dans la moyenne
étrangers et donc ne dise pas que c'est
des gens jeunes là mais là tout ce qu'a
dit oui non non moi je pense qu'il faut
pas il faut pas tout le monde lui tomber
dessus
ce que je pense ce que vous voulez dire
c'est que les gens qui font des formes
graves de covit sont des gens qui ont
une santé fragile et qui sont faibles
point final tout le monde souhaite à
personne de numéro 10 c'est juste un
référent cyclo dit les gens qui font les
formes graves sont des personnes faibles
et c'est tout et je pense que voilà
exactement ce que tu dis mais qu'est ce
que vous faut s'en occuper il faut il
faut s'en occuper car les médecins sont
là pour traiter des grâces et 3 to
gouvernement c'est d'avoir interdit aux
médecins de traiter les malades mais bon
on va revenir sur le cd parce qu'il ya
plein de gens qui réagissent dessus et
là ce débat il fait énormément parler ce
soir là comme tout le monde à ses seins
est ce que quand on est vaccinés on peut
transmettre la maladie et 2 est-ce que
vous retournez vacciner on peut encore
rattraper puisqu'il ya certains cas où
des gens la trappe ça ces trucs 2 je
voudrais répondre tout de suite à ça et
vous parlez feature dénomme du kentucky
alors cette fois les notes alors il ya
au kentucky c'est un état américain je
connais pas d'accord alors ya un lien un
monastère bénédictin qui s'appelle
warburg jusqu'en bon c'est le nom du
monastère s'affaisser à rebours est dans
ce monastère il ya des nonnes
bénédictine qui ne sortent pas et depuis
le début de l'épidémie et sortait pas
d'accord on y aille à la guichetière qui
est très liée à l'entrée etc et vivait
sans maladie elles ont été testées en
janvier de 21 et aucune dette est malade
et puis elle est âgée senonnes donc
elles sont fait vacciner
et depuis il y en a eu deux qui sont
mortes et vingt qui sont devenus malades
decaux vide alors qu'on me dise que la
vaccination protège contre le coni de
moi je veux bien mais qu'est ce qu'on
dit sur cette histoire d'amour des
histoires des notes dans le kentucky
au bout d'un moment peut-être passer à
autre chose vingt personnes qui sont
malades ok 2 qui sont mortes
c'est triste pour elle mais pas leurs
frais de l'épidémie moi je dis souvent
que le vaccin et voulaient casser si on
veut survivre il faut il faut se
vacciner ça diminue la transmission du
virus est là on regarde une étude où on
a regardé les personnes asymptomatiques
iront à voir qui ont été vaccinés et
bien en israël elles ont diminué de 80
qataris et si tu n'as été tant à la
caisse de vaccination alors évidemment
ils vont pas dire que le vaccin est
moche les israéliens montent au nord ça
nous la mayo clinic 88% de transmission
en moins je vous prends un autre hôpital
en angleterre 85% en moins la
vaccination mars et une chance juste un
tout petit point j'étais en centres de
vaccination ce matin ouais désormais on
vaccine aussi avec du moderna lago derna
alors vaccin et d'un arn comme le finder
c'est la même chose qu elle est beaucoup
moins cher il est aussi efficace et la
mer mais toléré parce qu'il ya plein de
gens aussi qui parle des différences de
prix des vaccins ça veut dire que c'est
incroyable c'est ça c'est du sang tennis
noires ne nous assure de rue
après quand on est impatient face de moi
j'ai des patients ce matin je devais
levac ce n'est que du moderna m'ont dit
non non je ne veux pas devenu fader ils
sont rentrés chez eux
je parie que c'est un drame mais il faut
mettre dans la tête des gens qui y est
que ce vaccin est très efficace et de
est médecin à qui je t'ai d2 et
dodgeball astrazeneca voilà est-ce que
ce faire valider la stratégie cas ou pas
si je pense que chacun est libre de
vacciner comme il veut je pense que
mieux vaut un vaccin avec astrazeneca
que des vacances henry a en quelque
sorte d'accord donc d'un côté le
meilleur vaccin à l'époque c'était le
vaccin qui étaient disponibles à temps
peut être dans une discussion
lorsqu'on parle notamment des femmes
enceintes et on sait qu'à partir du
deuxième trimestre il faut les faire
vacciner pourquoi car les femmes
enceintes au troisième trimestre font
des formes graves et donc quand on
emploie de la désinformation et qu'on
dit que le vaccin de sarria et bien
finalement vous allez avoir un impact
sur des gens qui vont malheureusement
alors je veux des essais quand même j'ai
regardé à nouveau ce que j'ai regardé à
grande et à y laisser finder un puisque
vous parlez de fighter est bien dans les
faits ce faiseur il n'y a rien sur les
femmes enceintes alors qu'était alors ok
j'ai un compte argument parce que vous
avez pas lu les et jusqu'au bout j'ai
une étude justement en angleterre sur
des femmes enceintes 4000 femmes
enceintes vaccinées
c'est vraiment un essai laissez moi
finir
un final laissez moi finir s'il vous
plaît vous vous dites qu'elle possède
des tueries
je me donne faim et eu un essai il ya
4000 noms avancés pas c'est inclus dans
d un protocole donnez-moi le protocole
parce que j'ai fait marcher là comme par
hasard juste alors juste sur les tares
centre gauche trouva gens les femmes
enceintes a beaucoup de charme en
simples qui nous regardent quinze mille
femmes enceintes qui ont un regard
intrus dans un protocole sur les vaccine
sur les vaccinent pas et on a regardé
est-ce que parmi les femmes vaccinées on
va voir plus d'accouchements prématurés
plus de petits bébés plus de décès et
bien finalement que la maman soit
vaccinée ou pas on a exactement les
mêmes effets secondaires ça veut dire
quoi que le vaccin est bien toléré et
efficace notamment chez les femmes
enceintes les femmes enceintes font des
formes graves c'est à dire quoi que
quand vous êtes enceinte au troisième
trimestre si jamais vous êtes rappelle
coronavirus est plus à risque d'aller en
réanimation d'être intubé et ventilé et
d'avoir une césarienne en urgence si on
a des femmes à 28,29 semaines qui ont
accouché le bébé est mort la maman a
survécu ou l' inverse donc je pense
qu'il faut arrêter avec la
désinformation et de ce maître dont
explique la vaccination est une chance
et je ne suis pas un vrp de laboratoire
ni du gouvernement
j'ai toujours fait très bien comment il
explique la centaine de cas en israël
deux personnes qui étaient vaccinés et
qui ont attrapé la maladie quand on
explique le vaccin n'est pas efficace à
100 % d'accord général
et puis il ya les variants qui donne
redistribuer les cartes et les variantes
sont favorisées par les vaccins
tous les gens qui ont étudié le problème
à l'évasion immunitaire et fès est
favorisée par le vaccin
delfraissy l'dit et ses 21 points pris
en 10 aussi il va falloir vacciner 90%
la population pour éviter l'émergence de
nouveaux variants parce que quand on va
se battre on sait pas c'est pas vrai
parce que les variants arrivé avant donc
vous allez vacciner 90% de la population
d'une part le variance est déjà arrivé
en israël quoi qu'il arrive et je pense
avoir il ya des gens qui demandent aussi
à ce que les des jeunes de 18 à 30 ans
vont pouvoir être vacciné un jour il va
falloir les maxi et les convaincre de se
vacciner
surtout pas pourquoi est-ce qu'on
vaccinerait des gens qui n'ont pas de
risque de la maladie en dessous de 30
ans c'est pas vrai qu'il y ait des morts
sauf des gens à très très fortes comme
d'air guinée serait morte par ailleurs
mais on sait on ce concert
comprendre je passe sur le discours que
vous avez eue sur les personnes âgées
plus faibles sur la bourse pas possible
quel est l'intérêt pour vous ce soir de
venir ici sur ce plateau
et de raconter tout ça aux gens qui nous
regardent au monde entier qui a et qui
s'est mobilisé depuis depuis des mois et
des mois pour créer des effets des mois
des vaccins posent est de faire 11 ans a
ému quel est l'intérêt dans votre tête
moi j'aimerais comprendre ce qui se
passe dans votre tête ou pour venir
diriger ce plateau ne fait pas le vaccin
tout ça ne sert à rien n'est pas dit ça
y est vous les dites des vieux non jeu
que des gens veulent se faire vacciner
c'est l'endroit le plus strict et je ne
le conteste surtout pas un vous avez
conscience des conséquences que vous
dites à la télévision française mais je
sais je le dis et je l'avoué humblement
cas vacciner les enfants si leur faire
courir un risque sans aucun filet disent
pas les 30 ans pas les enfants et
personnes en fait non j'ai choisi ce
lieu à risque à coup mobilité
effectivement c'est logique
encore faudrait-il que le vaccin marche
or il est bien heureux d'accéder vous
certainement pas avoir tellement
certainement pas parce que j'ai pas de
cobourne bénite et j'ai aucune commodité
et donc je vois pas pourquoi je je je ne
peux alors vous avez rien compris
l'épidémie est enfin là vous n'avez rien
compris à l'épidémie promenez-vous qui a
derrière sont pas un facteur de mourir
donc on a dû hausser l'âge de 75 ans 75
lots parmi les personnes qui risquent
d'aller en réanimation sixième année de
suite j'espère on voulait être après pas
mais n'est-il pas g class b retraite en
existe des traitements même si vous n'y
a pas nié par an hélas il y avait à des
traitements efficaces ou pensez
réellement que si la chloroquine
ivermectine ou la peau ne parla pas
marché on en serait encore là bas je
peux vous dire dans l'allier plusieurs
de mes amis qui ont eu d'effort vivent
dehors de mes amis aucun oui moi j'aime
allemande au bled elle a eu une fois un
peu de curcuma des jours
[Rires]
j'ai eu plusieurs effectivement des amis
qui est attrapant le covin lors de la
première vague 1 nous ont appelés au
secours en disant le mon médecin refuse
tout traitement qu'est ce que je
pourrais faire
on lui a donné ce qu'on pouvait lui
donner donc tout simplement qu est-ce qu
on donne quand une grippe des mauvaises
la grippe tue effectivement les vieux
qui sont fatigués qu'on beaucoup de coco
mobilisés à dax mais simon donne c'est
pas vrai du tout il faut les traiter
il faut les arrêter non mais si les
antibiotiques ça permet d'éviter les
conditions générales des antibiotiques
pas vrai ça a été démontré qu
effectivement la chloroquine par exemple
ou l'ivermectine interviennent le jour
1b oui parfaitement
vous refusez le dire de ces articles
c'est votre droit le plus strict vous
avez le droit de croire
géraldine écoutez moi je constate juste
que en angleterre où il ya une campagne
de vaccination massive brise johnson
parle de supprimer toutes les
restrictions sanitaires à partir du 21
juin qu'il n'y a pas eu beaucoup moins
de maurienne a eu hier 23 oui vous
comptez au jour
regardez ce qui s'est passé aux comptes
après après les vaccins dans la
vaccination
excusez moi c'est extraordinaire on sait
qu'après la validation bah oui mais bon
vous savez pas ce que vous en faites
vous partez du principe qui a eu une
épuration comme vous pouvez laisser ça
en fait c'est un massacre des vieux par
la vaccination
non mais
c'est le point de rencontre entre temps
je facilite ans franchement je change
mes mails et ce n'est pas fini mais non
mais je suis atterrée par ce que
j'entends c'est votre problème mais chez
eux mais oui mais franchement je vous
jure vous serez mon médecin traitant je
changerais sur le champ c'est à mon tour
de la conviction n'est en étant tous
vaccinés qu'on va réussir à lever sa
sale et la croyance il plus intelligente
delfraissy très bien vous disposer de
davantage de notions d'informatique
manger où êtes vous vous entendez ce que
vous avez à me prononcer c'est une sorte
de banalisation total de l'amendé mais
c'est messi la grande amie alizés
actuellement dit moins que la grippe a
dit rich
laissez moi finir elle a tué des
millions de personnes dans le monde la
grippe asiatique si on la remet à
l'échelle des populations a baissé il a
oublié ce que vous dites c'est le
laisser faire laisser aller vite mourir
moreau mais on me vantant de femmes
cieux delépine chaleur terrible
l'ultraviolence vidéo
non mais moi j'entends ce que dit
monsieur c'est vrai que ça fait un an
qu'on est cons et là dedans il ya
m'avance pas la population qui est
vacciné les chiffres ils sont toujours
les mêmes voir plus haut nous on a fermé
le gouvernement et emmanuel macron nous
faisait miroiter une sortie du coc vide
cet été on sait très bien que ce sera
pas le cas et moi je reviens à entendre
les discours de ces gens là quand tu
auras une une quatrième vague à la
rentrée une ville comme ça il aime bien
de temps pour pour préserver n'y avait
malheureusement la loi mais pardonnez
moi qu'on fait tous qu'on laisse les
gens mourir mais n'ont jamais cessé
d'aimer
sens de traitement sien je dis que c'est
scandaleux qu'on est interdit aux médias
vous avez dit papa guerre monsieur mais
c'est pas vrai c'est bien tout le monde
la moitié les indiens il ya peut-être
des gens devant leur téléviseur qui ont
perdu un parent ce soir et qui vous
regardent et qui vous entende et il vise
à bas ce monsieur a décidé que mon père
et ma grand mère c'est ce serait super
émission est la patrie c'est pas grave
j'ai passé 50 et gras et vous le vous
venez de dire qu'ils sont morts n'ont
pas de l'aco vide mais qui sont morts à
cause d'une vague il dépressif gestion
désolé monsieur retrouver les hommes
voulaient les 10 et 4 sur 10 sont morts
du vaccin oui parce que le vaccin dans
lorsque la l'immunité n'est pas
suffisante et ça c'est l'académie de
médecine qui l'a dit le 15 janvier l'a
dit attention si le nom santé on ne
remet pas suffisant vous risquez de
tomber sur un phénomène d'anticorps fins
âgé de 28 ans auquel c'est le contraire
de la maladie qui l'aggravent de dire
deux choses des bas et j'ai mis une note
d'espoir pourra éviter de plomber le
moral des gens et actualisée par pitié
vos connaissances je termine mes thierry
vautrât vaincu l'épidémie à lyon au
centre pour cent de la population qui a
été vaccinée et à partir de 40 % on a
commencé à avoir un effet significatif
regardez les chiffres derrière directes
62 % au royaume-uni un peu plus de 40%
les etats unis connaissent la même
cinétique ça veut dire quoi que avec 20%
on est à la moitié du chemin est donc il
faut se dire que quand on arrivera à 40%
qu'on aura vacciner les plus de 50 ans
on va décharger la pression sur les
hôpitaux et on va retrouver une
perspective d'avenir car l'enjeu est là
d'ailleurs demande aura n'aura sahara
non létales si l'on savait ce sera son
témoignage à viendra demain parce que
c'est il est incroyable son témoignage
oui vraiment donc si on a eu autant de
morts c'est parce qu'on a refusé de
traiter effectivement et c'est pas à
cause de l'absence de vaccin n'ont cessé
france et qu'il fallait voilà c'est vous
qui parlez de conflit apparemment
monsieur
un vrai complot contre la chloroquine ça
c'est vrais mensonges et ils ont été
retirés
s'il vous plaît regarder ce qu'en
pensent les gens faut-il s'inquiéter oui
à 67 %
non ben c'est bien dommage pour cent oui
c'est pas bon